as in a few hours president Trump's
former personal lawyer plans to give
explosive potentially incriminating
information about the president to
Congress now CBS News has obtained
Michael Cohen's prepared statement to
the House Oversight Committee
he plans to say quote I am ashamed
because I know what mr. Trump is he is a
racist he is a con man he is a cheat now
Cohen spent nearly nine hours yesterday
answering questions in private from the
Senate Intelligence Committee Nancy
Cordes is on Capitol Hill with the
evidence Cohen is offering which he says
proves that the president engaged in
possible criminal misconduct Nancy good
morning good morning and Cohen basically
lays out what he's got on the president
in that twenty page opening statement
that he'll read aloud today he says he's
got documents that show the president
was a tax cheat and a liar but Cohen
himself has pled guilty to lying to
Congress he's going to federal prison
for three years and he just lost his law
license yesterday so some Republicans
say he's not credible I'm gonna let the
American people decide exactly who's
telling the truth among the documents
Cohen says he'll turn over today a copy
of a check written to Cohen from mr.
Trump's personal bank account after he
became president to reimburse Cohen for
hush money payments to porn star stormy
Daniels the president has denied any
knowledge
[Music]
Cohen also alleges the president was
involved in potential tax fraud
inflating and deflating his assets at
times to reduce real estate taxes in one
bizarre incident Cohen says mr. Trump
told him to set up a fake bidder at an
auction to inflate the price of a
portrait of mr. Trump when it sold for
$60,000 Cohen says mr. Trump directed
the Trump Foundation which is supposed
to be a charitable organization to repay
the fake bidder
despite keeping the art for himself
WikiLeaks which I had nothing to do with
Cohen also claims the president knew of
contacts between his longtime advisor
Roger stone and WikiLeaks just days
before the 2016 Democratic convention
Cohen says in a conference call mr.
stone told mr. Trump that he had just
gotten off the phone with Julian Assange
and that in a couple of days there would
be a massive dump of emails that would
damage Hillary Clinton's campaign Cohen
claims mr. Trump responded by stating
something to the effect of wouldn't that
be great I've never used racist remarks
Cohen says that assertion is a lie -
while President Obama was in office
Cohen claims mr. Trump once asked me if
I could name a country run by a black
person that wasn't a blank hole and he
told me that black people would never
vote for him because they were too
stupid in an odd twist on the eve of
this hearing one of the president's
closest allies here on Capitol Hill
Congressman Matt Gaetz of Florida
appeared to many to threaten Cohen on
Twitter saying do your wife and
father-in-law know about your
girlfriends she's about to learn a lot
Democrats call that intimidation and
possible witness tampering
gates insists he didn't intend to
threaten anyone he has apologized Nora
and deleted the tweet never seen
anything like it Nancy thank you